- So this is your fourth time here, John.
- Yes!
- Do you know what that means?
- No, what does that mean?
- It's exciting times.
- Oh, wow.
- Justin, go ahead and bring it out.
- It means I'm easy to book.
- Yeah.
(both laugh)
You get your official -
- Oh, look at that!
- Every fourth time -
- Look at that!
- You're a member of the club,
You get a jacket.
- Oh, I'm in the club!
- Yes, yes.
- I'm gonna put this on.
- It looks good,
I'm just saying.
- Yes.
- It's a good jacket.
I feel like you wear jackets like this.
Maybe not with my name
on them, but -
- Yeah, I wear a lot of like
the bomber size jacket -
- Bomber kind of thing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's interesting,
Blake is actually -
- All right.
- He was here four times too.
- Team Kelly.
- He got a jacket and -
- Hey, Nick, you know how you get to be
on the show four times?
You have to be invited that many times.
I'm sorry, buddy.
- No, no,
no.
- I'm sorry, Nick.
- It's okay.
- He's just cooler
and busier than you.
- You have to be not busy. (laughs)
- No, here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
He's actually a member of the club too.
He got one last time.
Do you wear your jacket all the time?
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- All the time.
- God, yeah.
- That's so interesting that you wear it.
- I feed the chickens in it.
I feed the chickens in that jacket.
- [Kelly] Really, really?
- Every morning.
- So it's probably dirty.
- Yep, yeah.
- Yeah, you know,
it's interesting, is, nope!
You left your jacket
here in the green room,
actually.
- Oh, I did?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Whoa.
- Yeah, you actually -
- You ungrateful back!
- Neglected
to even throw it away
after leaving the building.
- You still have it?
- You, oh yeah, no, we've had
your jacket here -
- Oh, look at that.
- We're saving it for you, yeah.
- Oh, there it is!
- Oh, my goodness -
I been looking for this!
- Look at that!
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, the chickens will
miss it, yeah.
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] Yeah no, totally.
- I love you so much, Kelly.
- That's great, it looks
brand new, Blake.
- Yeah.
- It looks brand new.
- Yeah, that's interesting.
- Just to prove that it,
that I did, it says "Season 19"
on it, so.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Here's the thing.
When you don't like a gift,
you wait till you leave the building
to throw it away.
- I always leave the crap
you give me in here.
- [John] I mean, you give it away.
- You give me a gift
bag every time I leave
and I don't want you to waste it on me!
- The best part is your
people know you well enough
that we were like,
"So does he remember
getting the four times?"
And he won't remember any of that,
he doesn't remember the jacket,
I can tell you -
- I do remember that you let us drink
last time we were on this show.
- [John] Oh?
- I did, what are you saying?
- We had wine or -
- Would you like a drink?
- Yes!
- I'd like you to keep my gifts,
so maybe you'll get a drink
when you keep my gifts. (laughs)
- [John] All right!